okay I have what could be good or bad
news regarding Fox News Fox News for the
first time has been selected to moderate
a presidential debate yay or something
right they did a bunch of the Republican
primary debate they did Democratic
primary debates but they have not
previously done a Republican I'm sorry a
national presidential debate
so the presidential debate Commission
says Chris Wallace is our guy he's the
host of Fox News Sunday he will moderate
the third presidential debate scheduled
for October 19th in Las Vegas I will be
in Las Vegas on October 19 then we will
see if we were able to do any sort of
special coverage around that debate so
Chris Wallace appears on the program
media buzz on Fox News to discuss what
does it mean to you Chris that you've
been personally selected to host a
debate on Fox News and
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah really a lot of
blowing smoke I guess is what I would
call it and Howard Kurtz the host of
this program media buzz asked Chris
Wallace what will you do when one of the
candidates makes a claim says something
that you as a journalist know to be
false good question from Howard Kurtz
let's see how Chris Wallace answered it
well I understand that I think that's
the right approach not making it about
you on the other hand there's a lot on
your shoulders both in terms of the
question selection but also as they go
out of let's say Donald Trump and
Hillary Clinton what do you do if they
make assertions that you know to be
untrue that's not my job that's right I
do not believe that it's my job to be a
truth squad it's up to the other person
to catch them on that I I certainly am
going to try to maintain some reasonable
semblance of equal time if one of them
is filibustering I'm gonna try to break
in respectfully and give the other
person a chance to talk but I really
want it to be about them and gates I
want it to be as much of a debate people
often talk to the side this is
interesting right because on the one
hand it's true generally the moderator
is there to moderate and you'll remember
CNN's candy
Crowley was sort of destroyed by some on
the right when she tried to injure
interject just some basic fact during a
2012 debate between Mitt Romney and
President Barack Obama and whether the
criticisms were fair or not there's no
doubt that when the moderator attempts
to do any kind of fact-checking there is
a critique there on the other hand we
have a candidate in Donald Trump whose
entire campaign has been based on lying
and deceiving taking every position on
every issue and the idea that because
there's going to be equal time
there's no way Hillary Clinton could
possibly even deal with all the lies and
it may be defensible to say well the
moderator can impose just some
connection to reality there's actually a
debate technique called the Gish Gallup
and what this basically means and you
can look this up online and read about
it is you throw out so much stuff where
your opponent could not possibly refute
all of it even if it all warrants being
refuted and it can create the perception
particularly in the exact same type of
Native it nativist xenophobic but low
information voters that support Donald
Trump that Donald Trump has gotten one
over on Hillary Clinton the other
background on this if we want to look at
the associations is that chris wallace
is known to have a close personal
relationship to Roger Ailes in addition
to professional ties obviously Roger
Ailes was Chris Wallace's boss up until
a few weeks ago when Roger Ailes had to
resign in shame but luckily with 40
million dollars as his golden parachute
from Fox News for allegedly sexually
harassing 20 women Roger Ailes now is
advising Donald Trump and it appears
it's not a formal advising relationship
it may be informal but Ailes was on
Trump's plane and he's clearly part of
his inner circle it's not my job thing
becomes a little murky because we're
talking about a news organization here
ideally you would be finding truth and
presenting facts why even have Chris
Wallace moderate if he's not going to be
able to do anything you could get a high
school debate
and tell him to just click click a
stopwatch and keep time if really
they're just keeping time you can set up
I hate to break it to you Fox News
technology can be set up so that mic
volume is controlled by a timer and when
time has elapsed the mic automatically
goes off and if you really are having
the moderator there only to keep time
you actually don't need them and that's
why although I its face hey I'm not a
truth squad I'm there just to keep time
if you're just there to keep time we
don't need you Chris I hate to break it
to you
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDPS the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDPS